so hello everybody I have been very busy
in the last few weeks I've been doing a
lot of traveling I went to South
Carolina and did some talks with some of
the Orthodox churches there it was
pretty amazing so I was able to record a
bunch of stuff that I did there and
we'll be slowly putting it out on my
youtube channel when I'm going to post
today is the second talk that I gave
last at the end of October last year in
Seattle I was at an event with Jordan
Peterson and I presented two talks the
first talk was the talk on art which I
put out a few weeks ago and this talk is
one which is related to sacred space and
so I know that some of you have been
kind of following let's say the
discussion that's been happening between
myself and Jordan and this next talk is
a big part of the discussion that we're
having and so after this talk when
Jordan went back to Toronto he went over
some of the ideas that I that I brought
up in the talk and in our private
discussions in his second talk on Jacob
he kind of went back on the story of
Jacob and the ladder and went over some
of the points that I talked about and
also because of this talk that you're
going to see today and some of our
private discussions this is why recently
we've seen Jordan talk about the need or
the ideal possibility that we should go
to church now why did he get to that
hopefully this presentation will give
you a little bit of a hint about about
why well why you should go to church so
enjoy this
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
so the title of the original talk it was
supposed to be the truth in space and
time and as I was working it through and
I was preparing thing III really I ran
out of space and of time to talk about
time so it's only gonna be about space
and it's really it's really an extension
of its write the talk is an extension of
what I talked about yesterday yesterday
I was trying to one of the things I was
trying to do is to try to get people to
see what it means to enter into these
patterns that we talked about and to
enter into the frame of references that
we need for us to live in the world and
maybe even for the world to exist
properly and so that's mostly what I'm
going to do it's the the subtitle of the
the talk is also why you should go to
church so it's like metaphysics of space
and also why you should go to church so
hopefully that'll fit together somehow
so one of the things one of the things
if you were if you were all here
yesterday morning and listening to
Jordan talking one of the thoughts that
he's presented to us one of the the
things that he said right away when I
when I encountered his thinking at the
beginning that really struck me because
it it seemed to really jibe with the way
that I was seeing the world and seeing
the world through an Eastern Christian
perspective through an Orthodox
perspective is he talks about the idea
that the world in a way is too big that
the level of detail in the world is
unbearable it goes all the way down to
the sub you know subatomic field and so
we can't when we engage in the world you
know if scientists can stop and maybe
study these things but when you are
living in the world when you're walking
down the street when you're engaging
with people you don't live in those
fields you don't live in those those
those fields of existence you have a
field of perception and that field of
perception has a certain way that it
manifests itself and and a way the way
that it manifests itself is that you
beings are capable of focusing and so
for example like if you encounter a path
like the path that I've got in front of
in front of me we don't see all the
little pebbles that make the path up we
don't see all the blades of grass which
board the path what we see is a path and
there's something in us and it's and and
and and it's a in a Christian
anthropology we have the capacity to to
participate in logos you have the
capacity to participate in the essence
of the thing that we're engaging with
and so when we when we and we don't even
do it consciously it happens in it's our
human nature that's doing it we're not
thinking about this when we we encounter
a path we see paths and we know to walk
on that path so the way that I liked it
to schematize this idea is that the
chaos of creation the chaos is described
right there in the beginning of Genesis
this this unformed aspect of creation
it's still in a certain manner it's
still there it's still underlies let's
say the the experiential engaging with
the world it's still like lingers and
the world begins the world exists
through logos and spirit through word
and through spirit and of course like I
said it's not this is not something that
we we consciously necessarily do but it
is something that we participate in and
and and it's that's what that's what I'm
going to be talking to you about today
and so the problem is that if as soon as
you as you posit a fully independent
cosmos that exists in the way we
perceive it without us we run into a
brick wall like you run into a brick
wall wide array because you are the one
who is positing that independent cosmos
you are positing it from a existential
point of view from a first-person
point of view and so it creates a it
creates when you start to think about
that it can lead you to to madness
because what is the relationship between
the this independent cosmos because I
mean we're not positing that the world
exists just in our minds like that what
is the relationship with this
independent cosmos and then how is it
that the human being participates in
that and what does that mean in terms of
how we are made in the image of God and
so the the key to this for to me for the
contemporary world has really been st.
Maximus the Confessor so I don't know
who here knows who st. Maximus the
Confessor is okay so yeah we're in the
right crowd like at least let's say one
third of the people know the st. Maximus
the Confessor he was the seventh century
Saint and one of the things that he did
is he tried to take the first chapter of
of the Gospel of st. John the idea of
the logos the idea of the word of God
who's at the beginning and by whom all
things were made and he uses that and
and he melded with let's say the best of
what ancient philosophy had to offer and
gives us a cosmic vision a cosmic
Christian vision in which each thing
each person has a logos and and and all
those those Logie the plurality of these
of these Logie are gathered into us and
then our role is to gather those things
together and then to present them to God
too to kind of enter in this
relationship with God and and that
there's this this this unity and this is
kind of lifting up of the world it's
towards towards God and so his vision is
that the human being is uh is a
microcosm so here's a Maximus
so his vision is that the human being is
a microcosm that the human the constant
human being is constituted in a way in
that he is he contains the the heavens
and the earth he contains both the
higher meaning qualitative aspects of
creation and he also contains the
physical you know the earthly part and
and it's in man that those two things
are united and so it is our role to name
the animals it is our role to give
meaning to the world and that meaning
isn't arbitrary it's not it's not
subjective the way that people think of
subjective meaning today but that we
actually participate and in doing that
we are acting in the image of God we
participated how the world unfold let's
say and so there's a priest and scholar
his name is father
Drago's barium and he wrote an essay
called the anthropic cosmology of st.
Maximus the Confessor and it's really
interesting because this idea this note
was called the anthropic principle is an
idea in physics that's quite recent and
it and it is the idea that the universe
is finely tuned for consciousness to
exist in it and so there is this
relationship between consciousness and
the the fact of human capacity to
consciously see themselves and
consciously see the world that there's a
relationship between that and the very
shape of the universe so it resembles
the the idea of the of man as microcosm
who has in himself that say the
proportions of the entire universe but
there's also even a stronger version
which they call participate
participative anthropic principle where
there even posits the possibility that
without consciousness the universe
doesn't fully exist because as a for
things to be measured for the
proportions to
to be seen for things to have unity
there has to be maybe there has to be a
locus of unity something into which
those things kind of come together I'm
not a scientist
and so I've actually I'm really I'm
really an artist and so I'm actually
kind of touching science from very far
away and looking at it you know I used
to actually dislike it quite a bit and
it's actually Jordan who's who's kind of
been my reconciliation with science it's
all the way so it's oh this just might
sound just like gobbledygook and just a
bunch of you know thinking up in the air
and so I'm an artist and I the one thing
that I understand and the one thing that
I can perceive is space and so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to talk about
space and how space in our human
engagement can exist okay and I'm going
to show that to you as much as I can now
the problem with space is the same
problem on a more limited scale as the
idea that the world is too big is that
space is boundless right space just goes
on from in every imaginable imaginable
direction so I'm gonna give you and then
we need markers of let's say we'll call
the markers of place to differentiate
unbounded space from here right from
from an actual defined place so let's
say I'm a say I'm a pirate and I bury a
treasure and I and I bury a treasure in
a huge like immeasurable desert this
huge field that has no vegetation that
has no that has you know nothing in it
and I go there and I hide a treasure now
the problem is that I have no way to
tell people how to find my treasure
there is there's no possibility for me
the only way that I can
I can I can help people find my treasure
is if I create markers of place so I say
there's a cactus oh there's a cactus
it's that big you see the cactus walk 20
feet left from that you know walk 20
feet in that direction from that cactus
there's a big rock okay and then walk up
from that you know walk 20 feet in that
direction from that rock so in order for
the the place to exist you need to have
markers of space markers of place and
and what happens is they become centers
of space they become reference points to
all the let's say unbounded space that
lies around it and so I put a marker and
I say here there and from there that
distance and so that marker of place
becomes a center okay becomes a here now
once this is gonna be I abstract for a
little while but don't worry it'll land
into real life pretty soon now we can
understand right away that certain
things just naturally are better markers
of place tall things right so a tall
tree a mountain you know a pillar and
and and those types of things are just
naturally better markers of place so you
can imagine a group of hunters you know
thousands of years ago they're in the
forest they have to separate and then
they say okay well look up you see that
tree that goes up above everything else
well let's do our thing and then we'll
just go meet at that tree let's say so
people go do the thing and all they need
to do is look up they see the marker and
then they can converge into a place and
so there they're just certain things
that that function naturally as markers
of a place and the road sign is the
easiest way to understand that and it's
it's fully natural to our experience
some of these things are hard to think
about because they're so natural and
they're so part of our world that we
don't think that they have a form that
we don't think that they have a shape
you you can't make a road sign that's a
flat marker on the ground you you they
would be absolutely stupid to do that
because how are people who come to it
are going to know what it is they'll
have to come right up to it and look at
it on the ground you lift it up on a
pole and then everybody on the different
streets can just look up and they can
use that as a reference for them to know
where they are and what these directions
are okay so if you if you if you think
about that just for two seconds you
realize that it is the it is the ground
of really strong presuppositions that we
have we of ways that human engage with
the world maybe even without thinking
that that's what they're doing and so
for example trees obviously are a
perfect example of that like I said and
the tree in the Garden of Eden has that
function as well the tree is in the
center of the garden it is the the axis
of the garden it's the axis of the world
it's the reference point by which the
space of the garden finds its reality
it's the ultimate here right the here of
the entire cosmos would be that tree in
the garden and that's why as Christians
we say we find ways crazy there's all
these crazy traditions which try to find
ways to tell you that the Cross is made
out of the wood from the tree that's in
the garden because we want people to
understand that the cross is the same
thing as the tree in the garden it is
the center of space the center of
Christianity and it acts as that as that
pillar to which we all look at as the
reference of where we are and who we are
so we can see that it really is the
basis of basic basic things that we know
and that we do and we don't think about
like for example a fire
poll has exactly that function right the
idea of raising a cross or the idea of
planting a flag planting a flag on the
moon likewise it's like it's the most
absurd thing if you if you don't see how
there is something innately in us which
understands that a vertical marker has
that sense of here this is a place now
and it's a place if I put a flag of the
United States on that pole it's a flat
it's a place that marks my identity
relating to this place I own this place
ok so the idea is that a flag like I'd
say a flagpole right it doesn't it
doesn't just mark a place in an
arbitrary way so you can you can imagine
people standing around and then looking
together at the flag and what it does is
it says these people are in the same
place and are participating in the same
identity as they are looking at that
flag together it's not even a metaphor
it is actually creating unity relating
to a specific identity say it's it's
actually happening there's a story in
the Bible that talks about this there's
a few I'm gonna give you a good example
and one of the the best example is the
story of Jacob so I'm gonna read that
I'm we're gonna be the actual text so
Jacob is is going out to find his wife
so he leaves his home and he's going to
find his wife and so in the in between
he's in this no-man's land he's
in the land of the foreigner he's in the
land of the like he doesn't know he's
travelling somewhere else he's an inn
he's an in-between space so it says when
he reached a certain place he stopped
for the night because the Sun had set
taking one of the stones there he put it
under his head and lay down to sleep he
had a dream in which he saw a stairway
resting on the earth with its top
reaching to heaven and the angels of God
were ascending and descending on it
there above it stood the Lord and he
said I am the Lord the God of your
father Abraham and the god of Isaac I
give you and your descendants the land
on which you are lying your descendants
will be like the dust of the earth and
you will spread out to the west and to
the east to the north and to the south
all peoples of the earth will be blessed
through you and your offspring I am with
you and will watch over you wherever you
go and I will bring you back to this
land I will not leave you until I have
done what I promised to you so when
Jacob Oh wakes up from so when Jacob
awoke from his sleep he thought surely
the Lord is in this place and I was not
aware of it
he was afraid and said how awesome is
this place this is none other than the
house of God this is the gate of heaven
so Jacob is traveling to find his future
wife he comes to a vague somewhere like
it doesn't say where it just says he
comes to a place he doesn't it's just
nowhere just someplace on the way it's
not it's not aware yet so he stops and
he lies down on a specific stone and he
has a dream he dreams of a ladder which
reaches from hearth from earth unto
heaven and on the ladder
angels are ascending and descending at
the top of the ladder there's God of
course in Christian terms we would say
that at the top of the ladder
was Christ it was the logos and that's
what is traditionally represented as
at the top of the ladder so what we have
is a vertical connection between heaven
and earth between meaning identity and
the undefined still chaotic space in
which he is sleeping and God says I am
the God of your ancestors I am the God
of who you are right I am the God I am
the God of the origin of your identity
now this place where heaven and earth
meet
will become the center and the marker of
a space which will manifest your
identity right so God has already said
I'm the God of your ancestors and now he
says I will give the land to the
extension of your identity to your
descendants who will extend your
identity out from you and they will
spread to the west to the east to the
north and to the south and they will
become like the dust of the earth so
once again notice how this is the
establishment of a particular place out
of which one can measure the four
directions because you know the four
directions don't exist in themselves
they're extensions of points of
reference right there is no place in the
world that is objectively East or
objectively West places are always west
of something east of something so
Seattle is west of Montreal but is east
of Japan right
without that fulcrum without that here
there are no directions so Jacob
wakes up and he's somewhat terrified to
have had this revelation and now it's
his turn to say here this place is a
center of space
it's the house of God and why is it the
house of God it's the house of God
because it's the gate of heaven it's the
place where I found where I've
established where I've been given an
identity in space and an identity for my
lineage right by the God of my ancestors
so what does he do he puts up a stone he
takes this stone from under his head and
he puts it up as a pillar the vertical
marker of place and then he anoints the
pillar so I'm not gonna go into the
symbolism of anointing but but let's
just say very briefly that to pour oil
on something from above in order to set
it apart is exactly to say this this
thing this place right when you anointed
king it's to tell all these people
there's a crowd of people and everybody
looks like they're they're just you know
a mass of people and then I go up to one
person and I say this person and I pour
oil on their head and I say this person
and it raises that person up above the
other to become the marker by which the
others are identified with okay so to
pour oil on a pillar has the same
function just to say this place and so
and then Jacob names the place which is
important he says this is Bethel this is
the house of God so one can understand
that the pillar isn't just this vertical
thing right it's not just a a marker
that marks our place but it's a
manifestation it's a way to show the
inner vertical ladder which he saw in
his dream so the the visible pillar
reveals the hidden bridge the hidden
relationship between meaning and facts
between the the heaven and
so what's important to understand is
there's always two aspects of a center
of space the first is the invisible part
right the individual part of why I say
why there's a pillar why there's a
marker in the first place it's the
invisible logos invisible reason which
binds something together it's why I've
chosen a place you know in the first
light there's always a secret reason why
I say here right why I say now there's a
reason why I do that it can be home it
can be you know school it can be and
that is the secret reason why I give a
marker to to to a place
so the idea that Kaos is gathered into a
point into a purpose and and the the
purpose the ultimate purpose let's say
especially in creating a sacred space
the ultimate purpose of creating that
point of reference is to show the very
process by which that happens is to show
it's to find a purpose but the purpose
is to find a purpose you know it's a
it's a meta purpose it's it's it's this
showing that the we create a center to
show everything else how it works how we
participate in the world how it is that
the world works through these axes
through these fulcrums which which which
which then spread out into into the
world so in Jacobs story we see really
see like the positive aspect the
positive active of space this idea that
it's like you plant a seed right and
then this seed then spreads out into the
four directions we have this image of
the tree in the middle of the garden as
the ultimate axis of the universe and
out of those out of the tree the four
the four rivers flow in the four
directions to spread out until the ends
of the world and to mark the world as a
continuation of that one sacred pillar
and if you look at representations of
the cross especially representations of
the cross in the first centuries of
Christianity they would put the cross
and then at the bottom of the cross they
would put these four rivers the same
rivers as the river in rivers of
paradise to say that the cross is the
same access the same pillar which marks
the the center of the universe out of
which all are referenced all our
references point to so in Jacobs story
it's really the positive aspect but
there's another story which shows the
negative aspect which shows what happens
when the pillar isn't there or what
happens when there is no marker of here
a marker of us right a marker of of now
and it's and we see that in the story of
Moses
so in the time of Moses when the
Israelites had fled Egypt and were
wandering in the desert the Israelites
had been complaining and so God sends
serpents to bite them right so what's
the first thing we say when God is a bad
dude and religion is stupid right
sending snakes to bite people so we can
say that or we can pay attention for a
few minutes and see that that this is
actually talking about the nature of the
universe now there's a relationship
between being bitten by snakes and
complaining now that doesn't seem
obvious on first reading but it's really
there to complain against God is to
disassociate yourself to distance
yourself from the source of your being
right it's to say that the source of all
things shouldn't have done things the
way that they're happening now right I
am in discord with reality and to
complain isn't to make things better
better either right it's just to grumble
about how unfair life is so the
Israelites they complain when they were
in Egypt and now they complain when
they're no longer in Egypt and everybody
knows people like that and sometimes
we're the people like that you know
someone who complains complained when
they were single they complain when
they're married and they complain when
they're divorce right and it's never
their responsibility they're in there
they refuse to align with reality right
they come and to complain is to doubt
and to doubt is to fall into chaos I'm
not saying there aren't moments to doubt
obviously there are moments to doubt but
when that happens for better or for
worse its to lose the thing that binds
us together
that's what doubt does okay whether it
be those things that bind you together
as a person you know or that binds you
to the people around you or it could be
that binds you to a scientific theory
doesn't matter when you doubt all of a
sudden
something that seemed to be holding
together you start to think that no it's
falling apart or that it doesn't it
doesn't it isn't holding together so you
when you doubt you fall into this mom at
least a momentary chaos until you find
something to bind you again and to bind
things together again so this image of
chaos in the form of snakes rising up
and biting people who complain and doubt
is actually quite sensible in this case
okay so in order to fix this Moses has
to make a bronze serpent he puts it on a
pole and lifts it up you know as a
pillar of some kind and for those
Israelites who looked at the snake were
saved from the chaos and those who
didn't
they gave into the chaos and they died
so Moses set up a marker of a unitive
place in the chaos it becomes like this
axis that I've been telling you about
and those that were willing to
participate in this newly defined space
this newly divine place that was given
because you have to picture it in your
head right you have to picture all these
people dying you know and then Moses
takes this bronze serpent and he lifts
it up on this pole and then altogether
all those that turned their heads and
looked together at the same thing in the
same direction towards this center right
you have to see it in your mind because
then you realize that you know the
simple fact that you as a person or that
you as a group or in any situation that
you are if you are capable of rallying
in unity and looking above the pettiness
of what is is devouring you and find the
thing that binds you together
that is the cure to the chaos always is
the cure to the chaos and so by by by
looking
the serpent altogether they were
literally creating unity inside the camp
of the Israelites it's not a metaphor
they were coming together looking
together trusting in one point trusting
in one thing and finding that unity
which solved the problem of everybody
bickering in their corner let me give
you an example today standing in unison
looking at a flag and pledging in unison
or singing in unison your trust to that
flag and to what it binds together in
terms of identity doing that is an act
that binds it doesn't signify unity but
it is an act of unity in itself an act
which limits chaos because we are all
directed towards the same identity but
when we doubt when there is discord and
people no longer willing to trust to
look together to that flag let's say
well the Serpent's will come soon and
there will be division and if it goes
far enough people will die in the
streets and like I said I'm not saying
that there's never a moment to look away
to pull ourselves away from the makers
of unity there are moments in history
where we wish that more people had done
so but if we do pull away we should do
it understanding with reflection with
the knowledge of the consequences and
the awareness that the forms we have the
forms that bind us together are not
arbitrary and chaos is always at the
door so the pillar is one way to mark
space it's almost like the possibility
of space there's another way to mark
space and that's to contain space
and the simplest way you can think of
doing that is by tracing a circle right
tracing a limit which binds a place so
the the line the fence the wall is to
show the boundary of influence write a
protection from that which is not under
the influence of the identity which
binds us together in that space in that
place so we put a ring on our spouse's
finger we put a circle around them and
we say that belongs to me and that other
person we belong to each other
right and that and the visibility of the
ring and I don't have one because my
wife is wearing mine it's like I'm
showing my finger and there's no ring
there the visibility of the ring acts as
a warning that this person belongs to
someone already okay so you can see how
the the pillar doesn't necessarily have
to be represented for the the secret
pillar this secret connection to meaning
is found okay so I tried to find the
example that is the closest to everyday
life that I could because I could think
of because I've been taking you on some
abstract thinking it's alright I'm sorry
about that so the notion of putting your
things in a bag to contain them I have
to get this right cuz it's difficult so
the idea of putting yourself your your
your your things in a bag to contain
them you actually why would you do that
right there is no obvious reason for an
iPhone or gym shorts and water bottle to
be together in the same place right
there's no there's no natural reason for
that but there is a reason there's a
secret reason why those things are bound
within a contained space so the secret
reason is maybe you're going to the gym
and so all of a sudden that reason that
identity is contains those objects
together in one
contained place right and so the secret
pillar that secret pillar which connects
all of those things together to heaven
in a very little way it's a very little
pillar to heaven okay you know it's very
small that going to the gym but it is a
logo so it is a reason why those things
are coming together to create a unity so
the the this circle this boundary can
can multiply itself into many borders
and separation and and this is all in
order to show this progressive dilution
of identity out from the borders so and
that might seem weird but it's actually
every we we do this all the time it is
it is the most natural thing in the
world so for example imagine you're a
settler in in the Oklahoma land rush you
know of eighteen eight 1889 and you go
out amount amongst the mass of people
and you're all rushing out into this
land so then you find you know we have
spot where there's no one and you stake
your land and then you say here mine
this place belongs to me it will
manifest my identity in a particular
place so maybe what do you do maybe you
make a fence around your land especially
at the beginning when the chaos is still
kind of going on you want to make sure
everybody knows that that's your land
and you don't even have to make the
fence very tall you don't have to make
it so that people can't go over it
you just have to trace it so that
anybody who comes across that fence and
is wandering around your land they know
and you know that they're in your place
and that maybe they're trespassing so
then maybe then you build a house and
you have a porch on your house and the
porch on your house is nice because
strangers can come you know come into
your land they know they're in your land
then they come to your porch and then
you can open the door and then you can
engage with them you can trade with them
talk to them and you actually don't have
to know them that well it's ok because
there's this this this part of my of my
identity that is more outward and then
you go inside and then maybe you have
a living room and then within the living
room then you know acquaintances can
come and sit with you and people that
that you've imagined that you've talked
a little bit with you know a little bit
more they come in and they sit with you
in your in your living room then you
have your dining room and there you sit
with your close friends and your close
family and you have dinner together and
finally you have your bedroom and you've
created a hierarchy of intimacy that
moves from the unbounded outward world
through the stranger to the friend to
family and then to you and your wife
maybe and that space of your room is for
you and maybe for a few members of your
family and strangers know not to go in
there I don't know you know why do they
know that why do we know not to go into
someone else's bedroom right that that
hierarchy of intimacy and the movement
from the outward world into that
hierarchy of intimacy is necessarily of
movement from the many into one it has
to be right it's the very nature of a
circle very nature of any concentric
space which moved into out from
unlimited multiplicity into the unity of
one thing one thing that binds it all
together okay
so it can be for your own self that
let's say would be that intimacy of
yourself but also it can also be for a
society like I talked about with the
flagpole it has the same thing all these
people are around the flagpole but then
there is this one thing this unity and
it's it's not a metaphor it's like it's
really that it's happening that one
flagpole is acting as the point of unity
for all this multiplicity
so well that's a bedroom sorry so the
story of Jacob Jacob is there at the
pillar okay he he vows to serve the god
of his ancestors he gives the reference
point to the land you know and he gives
the place a name but an important way he
is also that pillar in that case right
remember that the pillar was identified
with his head it's not it's not
arbitrary why his head and the pillar
were identified together and then his
descendents spread out away from the
central pillar becoming more and more in
quantity moving in all the directions
and then becoming like the dust of the
earth reaching innumerable and unn
calculable quantity okay so we have
quality in the center and then quantity
moving out from the quality but the
question is I've given you like a basic
idea of this and I want to show you how
it works in society and especially how
that works in Christianity how do you
bind more and more people together how
do you do that well there's only one way
you create higher and higher markers of
identity and you do that physically but
you do that but what's important is
mostly to create the highest possible
marker of identity the highest possible
invisible marker of identity and that is
the role that Christ who is the god man
who is the ultimate unity of all of
divinity and all of humanity together
that is the role that Christ plays and
that's why the cross becomes the center
of the cosmos
and so the church does that
that's why church buildings are I've
traditionally always been the highest
building right that has just been
something that until very recently was
commonly accepted you know you can
imagine yourself in a Cathedral in
England or in Constantinople in the 11th
century and everybody in Constantinople
anywhere they were in the city could
look up and see the cross on the dome as
the marker of this space of this of who
we are in Quebec where I'm from it's
very stark because the way Quebec is
made is all these small villages that
are out in the woods and out in the
countryside so you're driving in and all
of a sudden the first thing you see peek
out is the church spire and you know by
seeing it you know that that's the
center of town that's where the church
is and then that's where the Mary is
that's where the bank is that's where
all the things that define that town are
there's an amazing painting by Mia which
shows the the prayer the Angelus prayer
as you can see here the church peeking
out sorry okay
and so these peasants are out in the
land they're working their land right
and then suddenly out of nowhere from
the church spire itself from the church
tower comes this ringing of bells and
then that everything stops and then all
the peasants in all the lands without
even seeing each other they know that
they're all stopping and that they're
praying together and the source of that
prayer they can all look the turn and
see the church spire the church the
church tower there as the marker of the
unity of their
village as the marker of their unity
with all of Christendom at the same time
and so they are for that single moment
they are fully participating in their
own in the ultimate reality and their
ultimate identity and the church the
actual physical building of the church
it unites the two types of spaces that I
talked about it unites both the vertical
space the idea of this high marker that
we can all look towards - but it also is
created in a way that is built with the
inner concentric space as well now here
I wanted to show you this this is a
medieval representation of a town right
and it's and it's schematized to show
you what the town is what it is and you
can see it's the same image I showed you
of Jake Jacob and his pillar and so in
the centre of the town is a cross pillar
that rises up above everything and then
from that pillar there are four roads
four directions for gates that and then
a wall that binds that village in all
its totality and so the inside of a
church has the concentric model now okay
the narthex of the church which is the
buffer zone here this is where people at
least in lace in an Eastern Church okay
that's where I'm from so this is where
people this is where people come from
okay they come into the narthex and the
narthex
is like a buffer zone between the inside
and the outside okay
so it is it is part of the church but it
is the place where the church
communicates to the outside and
traditionally you know in ancient
Christianity that's where the catechumen
would be brought when the time for
communion came the people who were who
weren't fully yet baptized in the church
would be take
out of the church and would wait in the
narthex and then they would shut the
doors of the church for communion to
occur and so it really was that and
those catechumen are the transition
between the inside and the outside they
are physically literally that transition
and so they enter into their space and
then we have the nave where the faithful
gather then we have the sanctuary and in
the sanctuary is mostly for clergy and
then in the sanctuary you have an altar
and then on the altar you have a cup and
then in the cup you see where I'm going
there is this consider this amazing
concentric movement which brings it to
this invisible place this place which is
the place where Jacob put his head down
on the rock it's the same place
it is a pillar between heaven and earth
which will then be taken distributed out
to the faithful and in food and then
those people then go out of the church
go out into the chaotic world carrying
that identity moving out into the field
doing their work and then looking back
and seeing the church spire in the
distance and remembering memory is
memory is the thing that binds us to
that pillar when we are not let's say
when we move out from the pillar right
there's reason why Christ say do this in
remembrance of me
when I go to the gym and I take my
things out of my bag and I put my water
bottle on the chair that water bottle is
still in communion with me even though
it's not in my bag anymore I put it on
the chair but it's still in communion
with me because I remember that water
bottle in the despite the fact that it
is distant from even the bag in which I
put it the memory of that water bottle
will make it so that when I leave I'm
going to pick the
and put it back into my bag so as we
move out of the church as we move out
into the chaos the memory of God is what
keeps us connected to God so if you just
take that one thing and you remember all
those stories in the Bible the story of
Noah
we're at the and at the lowest point of
the flood it says God remembered Noah if
you look at the story of Jonah we're
down in the bottom of the well in his
lowest point it said Jonah remembered
God that memory of God reaches down into
the depths of death to the depths of
hell
and what's mostly important to
understand when I'm talking to you about
about this is that is I want to help
people to see that this is not a
metaphor when we go to church when we
stand together when we look toward the
altar together when we sing in unison
you know when we bow down before the
altar why do we bow down we bow down to
acknowledge this thing we acknowledge
what is our the marker that unites us
together what is the source of our being
what is the source of our existence we
make ourselves lo2 to participate fully
in that and that's something you can't
do as a just a mental game if you've
never physically laid your face to the
ground you know before the altar if you
if you if you've never bowed down you
don't know what it is completed you
participate in that right it's when we
go to church it's not a metaphor we are
we are participating in an actual unity
by all the things that we do there's
nothing that's arbitrary everything that
we do is for us to participate fully in
that movement towards that invisible
pillar in that movement towards the
cross towards the tree in the garden all
of that is happening physically right
and and to do it physically is to make
your whole
being part of that process so that when
you leave the church so that when you
move out the memory of communion the
participation in communion follows you
to the in the deepest way that you can
imagine and then them and the memory of
that communion becomes the thing that
brings you through until you come back
together physically together in that
space and recite things at the same time
you know you have no idea what it does
to people to recite things
simultaneously right there's reasons why
like there's reasons why totalitarian
regimes have people do that because they
know that it binds people but what does
it mean when we can do that for the
highest thing we're not doing it just
for an ideology we're not doing it just
for some political utopia but we're
doing it for the very source of who we
are and the very source of everything so
I think that's what I wanted to present
you today so thanks
so I hope you enjoyed this talk on
sacred space there are a lot of things
happening very soon the next movie
interpretation I'm going to do will
probably be the matrix I'm working on
that right now and there are quite a few
more videos that I'm working on it's it
takes up a lot of time so slowly I'll be
putting these out as as I have more and
more time to do this I still have a few
spaces left for my carving class in June
so if you want to spend a week with me
check that out in the links and also
yeah so support us on patreon share our
stuff and I'm always happy to read your
comments I'm not answering as much as
before because I'm just so busy but I
read all the comments and and I think
about it so so yeah so I'll see you in
the comments and talk to you soon